hi
i'm winston marshall and welcome to
marshall matters my new show with the
spectator
i'm a musician and i was a co-founding
member of the band mumford and sons
which i quit in 2021
at the time i had tweeted about a book
critical of far-left extremism in the
united states
all hell broke loose
i decided better to leave my band and
save my band mates the trouble then stay
and bring them under the bus with me
or stay and
self-censor so now that i'm on this side
of the parapet i thought i should use my
voice to find out what are the totemic
difficult and taboo topics that we can't
talk about
i'll be interviewing musicians artists
composers comedians everyone in the
creative industries to find out what
indeed is the state of the arts
and i hope you'll join me
[Music]
hello and welcome to spectator offices
in uh london
and uh today uh i'm joined live from new
york city
by conductor and pianist ignat
solzhenitsyn ignat is the conductor
laureate of the chamber orchestra of
philadelphia and the principal guest
conductor of the moscow symphony
orchestra
he's also an expert
on the work of alexander schwarzenez and
his father
ignac welcome thank you so much for
making the time uh i'm genuinely
thrilled uh in anticipation of this
interview i've been listening to your
performances of bram schubert beethoven
and uh proclaim
uh
prokofiev yeah excuse me uh prokofiev
was not someone i was familiar with
before this um because the classical
world isn't a world i'm actually that
familiar with so uh it's a world i'm
hoping i might learn a little bit about
today wonderful winston and uh so so
pleased to be with you and uh conversely
i hope to learn more about uh about your
part of the music world that i'm not so
familiar with so wonderful to be with
you and looking forward to
the chatting thank you
um so i want to start off by quoting you
if i may uh you said something in a
previous interview that has really
resonated with me you said
we play study and suffer for music for
some bigger purpose
and it starts by expressing a
wonderfully unselfish act
not just expressing me
but expressing another person
i think the context of this was that you
were describing uh your father is uh
believing an artist has a greater
responsibility than just to express him
or herself and that that implies truth
is not relative
that we can strive for it through art
and that that is the tradition of
russian literature
writing had a purpose larger than their
life or ego
so
jumping in there quite uh heavy guns but
for me that sort of implies that
that art and music is a moral obligation
is do you feel that way
uh it's a it must be classified as a uh
frightfully retrograde
and and uh out of fashion
uh approach i imagine but
to me it's obviously true
it's obviously so
uh if we take art
and and i suppose so much of it is
semantics so much of it is well what do
you mean by that term
uh if we think of art as the highest
the most pure
the most truthful form of human
expression
if we think of art as
a bridge
across which
humans of
very different
totally different
backgrounds persuasions
etc
totally different people can
understand each other better
if we think of art as
a necessity for
human existence in a way that
does not exist
does not occur
i think is the correct term in the
natural world
uh per se in the animal world
uh as much as we might love our dogs or
cats or other pets but we see and i
think most of us recognize their
their existence is is uh not devoid of
the spiritual
plane or of something more than just
food but it's it's limited obviously
whereas for us
uh this notion that that
there is more to life than stuff
and there's more to life than property
or property rights even
uh and and and uh there's
there's something beyond that and
there's something we need in our lives
maybe not every one of us
maybe not at every stage
of our lives but at some point most of
us
hunger for something more
and to me
more or less those are some of the ways
we can define art and if art is defined
that way
then yes
then absolutely
that is the
something like that is a is an approach
that
that i feel
is
as i said inevitable and and and uh
obvious to me
has it always been obvious to you is
that is that
presumably you were you were
started music at a very young age and so
being able to articulate
what you think about the importance of
art as you've just done is that that
that
was that instinctual to you from an
early age or
is it something that you grew to
appreciate as you as you got older
i'm sure it's evolved and deepened
uh i'd like to think so but uh
certainly it was in the in the water
as they say in my in my childhood
because uh i grew up of course in the
family of a writer
and in uh in the family where
you mentioned the tradition of russian
literature in my family literature was
so deeply valued
russian literature included but not only
russian literature of course
all the the great heritage of of the
past and present
so
and naturally that extends to to theater
and to
uh to
painting i suppose and certainly to my
eventually chosen metier uh to music
so
i would say
how i feel about all this is
more or less how i've always felt about
it except i'm sure
when i was beginning my my my life's
journey and beginning my journey as an
artist
these thoughts were perhaps not less
cogently
expressed in my own in in my own mind
yeah but i think the basics were were
there because again i think the basics
are part
are part of a
natural order
i think
was that was there a moment for you
where you felt
when the decision to pursue music and
the the decision to to
pursue truth
within this art form uh did that happen
do you do you have a memory of that
happen was there maybe a piece of music
that so moved you that you felt that it
was this was how you wanted to live your
life this is what you wanted to give
your life to because as you said
there is a lot of suffering involved in
creating and practicing and it's it's
it's it's not it's not easy it's it's
really a huge labor um
so
to make that commitment is is i think a
big thing for all musicians is was there
a moment for you or
how did that come about
it's hard to say that there was one
moment i won't say that but there were
because
the simplest way to answer that question
is to say that
as soon as i
learned what's what
and i mean that in the most rudimentary
sense
in other words it's kind of as soon as i
learned to first learn to play the piano
of course i wasn't thinking about
conducting yet
uh
it i knew somehow my life would have to
be
in it or connected with it um i just
knew that now there were there were of
course great moments along the way of
recognition
of illumination
the first time i heard a beethoven
symphony was it so happens in my
father's study and i had walked in
knocked on the door and and he said come
in and i came in
he was working as
he usually was but he would
very often be listening to music on the
radio or in some of his old vinyl
records which of course vinyl is now
back in fashion which is lovely but uh
and and i don't know which one it was
but it was one of the beethoven but i
didn't even know it was beethoven i just
stopped
in my tracks and
and listened and he listened
and we just sort of both listened for
some period of time
and and and i then finally
i asked this
what is this
who is this
he said that's beethoven and so that
that was a that that and i wish i knew
which symphony but of course it doesn't
really matter because what matters that
they're all nine of them are
of course uh uh uh
as great as anything ever written
but the point is that it
spoke to me so directly so personally
another moment i remember is
another composer who would become
extremely
important in my life and has has
continued ever ever since is uh my
compatriot shostakovich
but i heard his fifth symphony
which is actually a very famous piece
and probably his most famous symphony
but at uh 11 years old i hadn't heard
i hadn't heard his symphonies and i
certainly hadn't heard the fifth
and i was at a summer music camp where
the orchestra
not very well but
well enough to convey some sense of the
of the genius and the power and as you
say the suffering in that music played
played this piece and and it was just
overwhelming it was overwhelmingly
powerful
uh overwhelmingly
important to experience that kind of
direct power even more so of course live
than um as you and i know than just on a
recording
so so those are a couple of moments that
come come to mind
but i think the the the the key the key
point is that just
uh from from from early age
i just uh and by the way i didn't start
playing that early which could be two
years old or three years old very
commonly but in my case was i didn't
start at all until six and i didn't
begin proper lessons till nine
so but by
my pianist standards that's on the late
side but on the other hand very very
soon after that
i knew my life needed to be
uh somehow closely connected or just in
with music and in music
wow so an obsession then that that
you've pursued through that time
there's something that
that that resonated for me because
i remember uh
start when i started for music it was
never um
i never really philosophized about it i
just sort of did i did it i needed to do
it and then when i started trying to
articulate it i articulate it for me it
was i needed to express my this is me
expressing myself but what you've got me
thinking about really is this it's
actually there's a more this moral
obligation idea this idea that
actually it's it's the pursuit of truth
and
and we owe it to our neighbors to our
our fellow man to
uh pursue this art
it's just kind of thrown my my week a
little bit off because i i never
thought about it in that in that way and
and
has i found it very it's been really
challenging me uh in a very positive way
i think
it's a wonderful thing winston that what
you're saying in the in your response
and of course we it's it's very personal
and and i'm sure each one of us can
and should articulate his own way of
thinking that and so far be it for me to
kind of impose that as a as a
prescription on any but just it's really
a very personal interpretation
of of of what it means to be in in our
case you and i musician
and
and and really it's i think it's just
part and parcel of the broader
idea i think it's still universally
accepted rather universally accepted at
least in the western world
uh that um
that we are each of us part of a broader
whole
whether of a broader group whether it's
our
neighborhood whether it's our city our
country our
common humanity and as part of that
community
uh we each contribute what we can
we each contribute
our best one hopes
and we all have diverse talents and
diverse areas in which
we can bring something to contribute and
so if one senses that
ability and that talent and that as you
say
need to to articulate and express
something
something maybe greater than ourselves
then yes i think there's a moral
obligation
to
to serve
to serve others
uh partly isn't it i i hope that's not
too too grand diliquent to suggest
that's it's about more than just
me and my needs it's about more than
just me
maximizing my uh
market value or whatever is the
the economic term for that it's it's
about contributing something
and that does feel like a moral
obligation even if it's
a small one and a small
scale of one individual
um
one of the purposes of of this uh
interview is uh and
the various people i want to interview
is to look at
freedom of expression within the
creative industries and i know very
little about the classical world but i
have seen various
articles over the last
couple of years
about how uh
the classical world is coping with in
these sort of uh
culture wars and and
some headlines suggesting that
beethoven's
two white and two male and being
cancelled in some places and
racial quotas for
orchestras and
resignations over
the colonisation of the of the western
canon things like this now are these
real things are these palpable do do you
have you come across these kind of
phenomenon within classical music do you
um do are they something to be worried
about or maybe are they perhaps
overblown
exaggerated
ideas
well
yes they are a concern to me
and to many of many colleagues i think
to most
of my colleagues but of course i speak
only for myself
it is true that
headlines have a way of
being just that being
outsized
and and it's hard to tell the complete
context
and i wouldn't say that these
examples that you've
brought up which are all true
unfortunately
uh
i wouldn't say that they're prevalent or
dominant
in the classical field
yet
but
broadly speaking they concern me
because of
the utter misunderstanding
i think of
of human nature
that
stands behind them
and of the potential for
for destruction that is inherent
in them it's just speaking speaking
broadly
and i think that this is
uh this is a big big concern
in
in the world of
arts and really in the broader world in
the broader western world
at the moment it's a big concern because
the very values
that have made the west what it is for
better or worse
are
it seems not only under attack but are
are being doubted
uh by sort of by the very cultures or
countries or communities that have
brought them forth and i'm thinking in
particular about values of
tolerance and values of
uh
diversity of opinion and and
values of grace
listening to another's point of view
respecting another's point of view
making room for many points of view
and so forth
these are all
these are real concerns
and um are they do you feel like with
your contemporaries are these at least
conversations that can be had or
um uh
or is there uh a feeling that actually
it's a dangerous conversation to be had
um
uh winston your question is
appropriate and very depressing
because because think about what you
just asked and i know you have
is it a dangerous conversation to have
what
point have we arrived at
where
again thinking of and i just don't
feel qualified to speak about
broadly the whole world because there
are many contexts and many cultures and
many
different histories but but i do feel
quite confident speaking about um
one world is is this is the is the
traditional uh western
uh western under western world and
western understanding of tolerance
particularly the one that comes from
english common law
and and the one that has been
uh promulgated and amplified and
established in in the united states
with that very famous uh and enduring
constitution
uh
and
how can there be how can a conversation
be dangerous how can it be dangerous to
exchange points of view how can it be
dangerous to have a disagreement
but
it seems that
we are heading
precipitously
in that direction
and yes i think that
people are afraid
simply to
to say
really to say exactly what they think
it's a different question that it may
not always be
civil to say everything one thing so i
think we learned that from our mothers
or from our from our fathers that you
don't have to say everything that's on
your mind okay and it's quote
exactly the question of text and
question of
good manners and a question of
simply being kind sometimes it's kinder
to to to be mindful of others but
broadly speaking
why not to be able to speak freely and
to and to engage in discourse and how
else can one learn
and and and maybe change one's mind
um other than through a free exchange of
ideas
uh this this is a great concern but yes
i think people are
frightened and uh
unwilling to speak freely because one
never knows who's listening or who's
reporting you know that's another aspect
that i don't know uh
how you feel about it and what your
sense of it is but
but even just the faint whiffs that that
i come across
and it's i think it's more than that of
the notion of telling on people
the notion of reporting
as soon as a an uh
a view that somehow
uh ranges outside an increasingly narrow
orthodoxy
is expressed it must be
okay not engaged with not defeated
not exposed for the foolish
or or
retrograde view that it surely is but it
must be reported it must be reported so
the appropriate authorities can deal
with it
and this is this is star wars language
this is this is awful
and surely that's not the way to foster
understanding and community and uh
really that that that kind of universal
uh
tolerant society that i think everyone
is after i think
in it but but but how we get there
the means matter a lot don't they
absolutely i mean in in in the pop world
my personal experience has been um
having sort of
been reported on or whatever
is that a lot of musicians some of them
very well known have reached out
privately
and some of them are prepared to
speak out
in defense but actually
my experience isn't uh uh doesn't
necessarily bode well for speaking out
and um
uh
i i i can i i sense within pop music a
lot of people feeling like they can't
speak and actually again this is
this is why i value a conversation like
this is hopefully just by pushing the
conversation nudging it a little bit
it'll just make it easier and easier for
us to to speak and make mistakes maybe
we'll get it wrong and have these
conversations so that others can feel
like
they can they can speak
more freely
well the next thing i wanted to talk
about is that in the west i've noticed
over the last few years that your
father's writings are cited more and
more commonly
uh
and perhaps perhaps it's something i
i just notice it more but i i do i do
also sense that i read
a result of the sorceress and is often
quoted in articles i i read and
he's quoted at length in the work of dr
jordan peterson he's
there's a book called live not by lies
by rod dreyer i think his name and um
certainly in my life
i mean i quoted your father in my
resignation letter um
from his essay live not by lies
um it seems
that perhaps
his work is is resonating again
precisely because of these things we've
we've been talking about this
this sense of censorship and and uh
the
the way of the west at the moment do you
have an insight into that do you think i
might do you think i'm right in thinking
that his work is being cited more at the
moment
yes i do and i think that uh it has to
well it it has to do with
uh it has to do with maybe first firstly
with the fact that there was a
backlog
of uh his
translations of his works into english
of all languages
because of various
essentially uh mundane and logistical
issues but uh there recently in the last
eight to ten years they are coming out
uh kind of that that backlog is being
is being remedied
and these books are coming out with
increasing
frequency
for the first time in english important
social needs and text and so that is
eliciting a new new generation of
readers of commentators even now of
scholars who are specializing in social
media and uh in short there's a broader
uh renaissance of uh
engaging with social nets and art and
his thought
then the specific context that you
mentioned i think is is absolutely
evident because to the extent that
western societies
are
increasingly subject
or
tolerant of
this notion of for example censorship
censorship
used to be so to the extent that that's
happening yes social needs words
and and i and thoughts
are gaining uh
renewed application in context that
for which they were never intended
except that as all great art
i think
they are universal and so they are
effortlessly applied
uh to
in this case to the current
uh
cultural climate uh in
uh in in the west you mentioned live not
by lies and of course you mentioned it
so powerfully in your letter
this is a text i've known since
very young age it's a text that i
virtually know by heart of course it's
not very long
four or five pages
it but
it's a text i always associated with its
time and place
what was maybe just 30 seconds about
what is live not by lies for our viewers
live not by lies was the final
message of social needs in his final
text that he wrote
before his forced exile to the west in
february of 1974.
so it was a kind of a
kind of a last will and testament
uh to
to the russian people
uh not that he was
planning to die or or expecting to die
and but but just he he didn't know when
he would return if ever of course
and he summed up
his credo about
how he had tried to live in those last
actually his whole life but certainly
those last
so many years of his life in the soviet
union and how he
didn't even maybe to say implore others
to live but how he a way that he showed
that could be possible in this way as
you well know winston is saying you
don't have to be a hero you don't have
to
stand up in the public square and
condemn injustice
because it's too much to ask you have a
family you have children you have a job
you're not courageous by nature you're
not a superhero you're just a guy or a
girl a woman
you're just a person and
okay so you don't have to be a hero but
what you perhaps ought to consider
is
do not participate
in the lie that is all around you
in in soviet
communist totalitarian society it's all
around you it's at your workplace
it's in your home
it's on the streets
and just don't participate and he gives
examples of how
if of how one could do that
small steps a normal person a simple
person can take
that then
if more people did that could have
a
cascading effect
so that was a a
a suggestion
meant for those times meant for that
place for that country that was enslaved
by
an evil
anti-human
despotic regime
to think that that advice now can be so
relevant
to a free
people
free society in the west
is
until very recently unimaginable
but you're absolutely right it seems to
have
direct connection to
choices
that people can
do or do not make
in
in the west today
it's funny for you to describe it as a
sort of gentle
uh
text because for me actually
uh and i've read it a lot this year
particularly before um
resigning from my band or quitting for
the band and actually i just wanted to
if i may read
one particular paragraph which i read
over and over this year and
i didn't take it at all as a light like
i took it as a like a very um
a command even uh
something i felt
it it resonated it hit me so deep that
uh uh
there was nothing gentle about
how i interpreted it let's put it that
way
um and he who is not sufficiently
courageous to defend his soul
don't let him be proud of his
progressive views and don't let him
boast that he is an academician or a
people's artist a distinguished figure
or a general let him say to himself
i am a part of the herd and a coward
it is all the same to me as long as i am
fed and kept warm
i that's not a gentle
uh
piece of writing that i i want that
that's
that's tough that's like that's a brutal
almost uh
um
it's ruthless i would say even
if i misinterpret
i don't know if i could i see it the
same way or read it this or hear it the
same way as you do i know i understand
what you're saying
of course and it's it's strong
but i i think
i don't know if i would use the word
gentle and if i did maybe that wasn't
the right word but what i what i mean to
say
is there is that this appeal
is
meant to be and i think it is if one
reads the whole text as of course of
course as you have is is voluntary
this is i think it's important to know
and and to understand that he is not
this is not
a a a
like it or not you have to do this or
if you don't do this you're consigned to
eternal perdition
uh
it's he's saying this will only work if
individual persons
will stand up and he says it towards the
end if you remember he says
it shouldn't be so fr
winston this this this this
echoes something you said a few minutes
ago
he said maybe through our conversation
you said
maybe somebody else will be emboldened
to just
as you say to nudge the conversation a
little bit to be a little more tolerant
to be a little more broad and social
ethan says and live not by lies
there are already
persons today and he says even dozens of
them
so there aren't many
maybe maybe some dozens so
but who are living this way who are
living not by lies and he says so it
shouldn't be that hard
for you dear reader
uh
to consider joining them it shouldn't be
that hard you know you could do it
starting today you don't have to wait
somebody's already doing it and they're
not being shot or killed
as admittedly in earlier even
uh even happier times of the socialist
paradise under
lenin and under stalin okay now this is
1970s the period of stagnation you may
lose your job you may go
hungry
but but you won't be shot you won't be
killed
simply for refusing to participate in a
lie
at least in most cases and he and he
says and he makes that distinction
between violence and lies
how intertwined they are but also how
most people even in the soviet union of
the 70s won't encounter violence
directly
they will encounter
by some some of them will encounter
violence some of the time but all of
them will encounter or participate in
lies all the time so that's the only uh
maybe just
distinction and angle that i would say
is is that the words are strong but yeah
he just says if you don't do it
at least be honest with yourself
what that makes you
it makes you a coward it makes you yeah
so those are strong words but but um
but i think he knows that i'm sure he
knows
knew that uh his appeal only can only
work to the extent that it's voluntary
to the extent that people want to rise
from all fours
and to stand up on on two feet as a
human being should
yeah that that's uh just i'm sure that
that that piece of of writing will be
read for centuries to come and actually
i discovered it myself
quite late uh of of the the bulk of um
social news uh work and and yeah it's
it's easily the most profound and that's
saying a lot uh of of what i've read um
so um
i'd love to ask you uh
as a last question
what are you excited about what what is
on the horizon and um
what when can we hear you next
performing
it's uh it's been a long pause hasn't it
for
for many of us
and uh
what a strange strange strange time
but
one hopes that it seems to be finally
life in general in most places coming
trending more or less in the right
direction
and uh certainly one feels that in in
music and in the music world and
uh yeah i'm excited to be coming back to
concerts and and as a matter of fact
coming to london very soon and uh would
love to see you there uh performing at
wigmore uh wigmore hall
uh in london in february so one god
willing and uh coveted regulations
willing uh
you know that that will happen and uh
performing a program of late
shostakovich speaking of
uh at whitmore and uh
thank you for charles de kovich is the
soviet is cellist am i right he's the
great
have i got that right no that's raster
povich oh sorry
yep
a lot of uh sort of similar or rhyming
names certainly in russia but uh so
roster probably which is the great
cellist and conductor okay uh dimitri
shostakovich is
one of the great russian composers also
was a terrific pianist but that's
essentially a footnote now
because of this his tremendous stature
as a composer uh 1906 to 1975.
uh and so he would the revolution came
when he was 11. and so really he lived
his whole adult life under the soviet
regime and died
under the soviet regime and his his work
is
some of the most searing
and probing
and powerful testament
to to human suffering
and to the
to the depths
of
human
self-examination
uh to what how deeply we can
probe ourselves until we hit
not just raw you know meat i guess but
hit bone or hit
whatever hides behind the bone the
essence of of
of humanity
i think shostakovich does that in a in a
not only in the moving but really in a
frightening and
uh
deeply thought-provoking way
and uh and an emotion-provoking way
and uh i guess
those are some of the reasons that for
me he is
so so important
and so in bringing two works that that
were written in the last year of his
life uh
1974 75
to the whitmore stage
wonderful well i very much look forward
to it
as you say go willing it'll happen and
um
god willing the music will be back um
thank you so much for your time uh real
really special for me and um
uh yeah thank you for sharing all of
that and speaking winston you
you you are welcome and thank you for
asking me to join you and
uh i'm sure you've heard it
a lot but i think it has to be said
thank you for what you've done and i
think that what you've done
uh is
precisely i think the sort of thing
that my father was talking about which
is to value something
ineffable above
material things
and uh in your case
as you've said i think it would have
been much easier to just just
just go along continue with the with
your amazing success and with your
fame and and everything that goes with
it and sure that would be the easiest
protect your investment protect your
it's a but you did something
uh
simple and yet incredibly brave
simply by really as i see it defending
your right and therefore each of us
the right of each of us
to speak freely
and so for
this i thank you very much and i know
that
many of our colleagues do whether
publicly or more likely privately
and uh
bravo
ignet saltzmanson thank you so much
thank you winston
[Music]
you